The gaming screen, go to the gaming screen.
We avoided the curse of the streamers and actually booted up the game.
We wanted to.
Christmas.
Can I get a round of applause?
Round of applause, everyone.
It actually worked.
How is everyone sound?
Hello.
Blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
No scoffers.
Yes, some of the girls.
I think it was a volume good.
Oh my god.
I have volume.
Why are you almost 50?
I had to turn you down.
Oh my god.
Holy finally done it.
Wait for who donated that.
It's anonymous.
Anonymous.
100.
I'm tweaking.
Thank you.
We love anonymous.
Anonymous.
Okay, should I start the game?
Does anyone want?
Do you want more strokes?
Do you want more?
I would love more strokes.
You don't have to ask us twice.
Who wants to stroke?
I always go overboard.
Wait, we'll try the collision.
Yeah.
The collision will be funny.
What is collision?
Wait, what is collision?
We can hit each other.
Our balls touch.
Oh my god.
Did you guys customize your balls?
No.
No?
How do you do that?
We can hit each other.
We can hit each other's balls.
Oh my god.
Did you guys customize your balls?
No.
No?
How do you do that?
How do I customize my balls?
I can customize my balls?
Oh, two seconds.
Top left.
You guys didn't customize your balls?
Top left seconds.
Oh my god.
I can customize my balls.
Thank you.
Give me a second.
What's SIDUM?
SDMN?
Is it another option?
I thought you said SDD.
No.
It's in top left, customized ball.
And a foot SDMN on SIDUM.
Oh.
I have a flaming hot ball.
Now my ball has hearts.
How do you customize your balls?
There's one with X's in me.
There is?
Where?
Oh, I see it.
Yeah, I customize my ball.
How do you do that?
Left.
Everyone's so excited to have their own custom ball.
Oh my god.
That's amazing.
Beautiful.
Let me know when you're done customizing your balls.
I'm almost done.
I've customized.
Do I need to, like, radio?
Oh, I need to put a hat on your ball.
Am I ready?
I can't tell if I'm ready or if I'm not ready.
It turns green or yellow is ready.
Green.
Green is ready.
Oh, OK.
I'm ready.
Are you ready?
Yeah.
I don't think she is.
Well, oh, not every player is ready.
Not every player is ready.
I'm ready.
No.
I'm going to press the button.
Yeah.
Hell yeah.
We're in.
Oh my god.
Oh no.
We're in.
How do we play?
Aim, click, and tap.
What's happening?
Wait, what happened?
How do I do this?
Hello?
It's just so weird.
Oh, so weird.
What the fuck am I doing?
Wait, I don't know how to do it either.
Aim, click, and then pop the string.
Oh no.
Click and drag.
Oh yeah.
Drag.
I don't know.
Just to say.
This is so cute.
Azura will say thank you once the collabs over.
But thank you everyone who's supporting Azura.
We really appreciate it.
We love you.
Ignore me.
I think I know it's like a long road.
You're notification broke.
Can it not keep up?
Oh my God.
I think it's broken.
What broke?
That was trash.
No way.
How did you get it?
It's broken.
Oh, come on.
That was trash.
No way.
How did you get it?
It's broken.
Oh, come on.
Fuck get me off the fucking thing.
Hello.
Oh my God.
I'm still struggling to figure out how to play right now.
Oh, boogie.
You got this little sis.
There you go.
You're getting so kind of weird.
No, not the double boogie.
The double what?
The boogie.
The boogie of course.
The double boogie.
I thought it was boogie.
It's boogie.
Where's the hole?
Oh, it's my ass.
Oh shit.
Oh my God.
Wait, I want a hole in one.
I'm scared.
I hit it against the wall.
Damn, I got a hole in one.
Let's go.
Oh.
I thought I was going to be the only one that didn't get it and I was going to cry.
Everyone's anonymous.
Fuck.
Wait, all the donations are anonymous or?
Yeah.
Thank you, Anon, Anon, Anon, Anon, Anon, Anon.
Anon, Anon, Anon, Anon.
We love kissing too.
Anon, I'm trying to learn how to do this.
This is hard.
It is.
Fuck.
I'm hard.
Oh no man.
Oh, do you have?
I think Mercy has love hearts coming off of her.
No, I didn't mean to do that.
This is so bad.
There we go.
I am terrible at this, please.
I get it.
Triple boogie, that's fine.
We got this, Mercy.
We didn't play a practice round, to be honest.
We're just going to blend.
We just went all seven strokes for different folks.
Exactly.
Bruh, how are we supposed to guess where the map is?
Where is the hole?
Oh shit.
Fuck.
Oh my god.
We love you 150.
Thank you, Mr. Anonymous.
Are you serious?
Oh frick.
I can't.
It's really dark in this one.
I see, why are you on my backside right now?
I want to.
I do what I want.
I can't see.
I'll get the action shot, don't you get it?
Am I doing good at golf?
This is MLG Pro.
What a gamer.
Golf, golf, golf, golf.
No way.
Edging, edging, edging.
Edging the rim, edging the rim.
I'm so mad.
Oh my god.
Alright, here we go.
We got to do...
Don't do what, it didn't work.
It didn't work.
Where the fuck I am?
Come on, come on.
I'm in a hole.
I missed the hole.
What the hell?
I'm still in the hole.
Where the fuck am I?
Why?
Are you kidding me?
Who was that?
It was Zara.
Fuck this shit.
Me and Mercy are struggling over here.
I can tell.
I'm glad I'm finally not the one struggling in the game
for the first time in my life.
I'll take it.
Shut up.
Toxic golf.
Me and Mercy, we're fine on the bottom.
We'll lift everybody up.
I don't want to be on the bottom.
I want to be on top.
There.
Where's the hole?
Wait, what? You can come off this map.
Can I jump?
I don't know.
You can come off this map.
Right, enough. That's three strokes.
I keep trolling.
Stop trolling.
Okay.
Now we slowly...
Am I going to roll all the way back?
No.
What?
Stay, stay, stay.
Right, I'm throwing.
You should be riddled.
I'm throwing so hard.
Guys, guys, what the hell is this?
We ain't going to make it...
I'm throwing.
I'm going to throw.
Ah, no. Ah, no.
I'm...
No!
I'm going to cry.
Where am I?
Hello?
No!
I killed AC.
I killed AC because her balls collided.
I'm creeping.
I'm on the edge of glory.
I'm on a living stroke.
Who picked the main shaft?
What am I doing?
Isaac, the main shaft.
Of course.
Sorry.
Sorry, I have a salt.
I do.
Wait.
Is there a maximum amount?
There has to be a maximum amount.
It's 12 strokes.
Well, it can't be because I managed 17.
It's that one.
That's great.
I literally got a 17 stroke.
I guess it's not.
Shortened behavior.
Almost all in one?
That was...
One minute.
I needed to even the plane field.
Let's do this.
Come on.
I can't believe you, Mercy.
How could you swear?
That's so fucking stupid.
I got the trick shot.
Sorry, I said such bad words.
I will remember to...
Wait, how did you do that?
You're gonna f*** yourself?
I can't believe you're going to f*** yourself.
Oh my god.
This is so good.
Are you winning?
What the f*** is the salt thing?
It's me.
I put salt on myself.
It's like an additional thing.
Because I'm salty.
There you go.
I'm Scottish.
Didn't you know golf started in Scotland?
I have a racial passive to this.
I'm not even kidding.
Stop.
Please.
I may have thrown in that 17 round,
but I'm gonna bring it back.
I see it on the bottom.
Only one made up for all your 12 strokes.
Wait, what was that?
What was our map?
That was me having a mental breakdown.
Meet a real...
Let's go.
Strony, get out of my face.
Strony, help me up.
I love my breakdown.
Let's go.
I was doing so good.
What the f***?
F***ing map.
F*** this.
Are you reaching over golf right now?
Yes.
Because I always f***ing suck at games.
Give me a second.
I got a spammer in chat.
What are they saying?
Monkey.
I'm gonna fart on him.
This one's for you, buddy.
Shipping on him.
Shipping and farting so hard.
Shipping on them hard.
I'm tired because
I blocked that.
Motherf***er.
They keep pulling back.
What? That was like a pro strat.
Hold on.
Where the f*** is this?
Where did the flag go?
I found it.
It's like through the yellow tunnels?
Oh, I found it.
I'm so mad.
That was gonna be A++.
Why do I have to be behind
whatever the f*** this is?
What does boogie mean?
Three?
I think boogie is three.
I'm being hit.
I'm gonna start choosing violence.
And I'm gonna start targeting others.
Oh, no!
Sabotage us.
Wait, they're moving.
The goal is moving.
How?
What the hell?
We need to pick the easy peasy levels.
What is this?
It's a funner.
Where am I?
There's no way we're supposed to
just eat ourselves on top.
Let's do a little bit of this.
Let's do a little bit of that.
And then...
Sorry.
Never mind.
Please.
Please, I'm begging.
Let me come a little bit closer.
I'm gonna do...
I got this.
Bad timing.
It's okay.
We're still here.
Quick time event.
I don't think he's still alive.
I'm so easy.
I'm so hard.
I'm so close.
Wait, that actually almost helped me.
Where am I?
Let me go.
Let me go first.
What the hell was that?
Did someone get in the hole?
Damn.
I'm throwing myself on the train tracks for real.
I'm about to end it all.
Azura did it?
Azura got in the hole?
I'm gonna come a little bit closer.
No.
No, wait, how did I not get in the hole?
I was too early.
You got a mercy.
I got it.
Congratulations.
Thank you.
Thank you for the 25 Mr. Anonymous.
17?
Why did I get penalized 17?
No one else got penalized 17?
Why do you say it like that?
Penalized?
How did you say it?
Penalized.
Where's the thing?
Oh, it's over there.
Alright, let's go.
Wait, how did you say penis
and how did you spell penalized?
P-E-N-I
P-N-A
Oh, shit.
I don't know how to spell. Don't listen to me.
Don't listen to me.
Where's the ball?
In the hole.
The fucking train!
What am I saying?
What the fuck am I supposed to do?
Wait, any of these is the goal?
I wish I could have this day
that I've never played this game before.
Please, Ronnie. How do you say pen?
Please.
Pen.
Penalized.
Yeah, it's penalized.
I was in love with God.
He's so good.
He's my main chef.
He's in love with the Holy Goddess of Zerah.
That was far too hard.
I got a little...
Which one is the hole?
Are they all the holes?
Hole.
Oh, wait. The one with the flag.
Oh.
How am I supposed to...
Bonk.
I'm still at the fucking start.
Oh, yeah, I'm back in the fucking building relax. Oh, yeah, okay. I did it. I did it. I made it
I made that all right. Let's go
Now I just realized I forgot to turn off this
What what what you done?
What have you done?
Nothing, so they didn't do anything. Did you have your background music on?
Mine is I saw my background music on
Okay, all right, where is it?
I'm going this way. I'm following in me spanked it rather gently that time do apologize. Let's try that a bit harder
I'm on X games
I
Someone literally goes in my stream I switch streams just to say it's pen
I'll lies. Okay, dude. Okay
Pino I get penalized for being a lucky boy
I see
You guys suck it
I
Birthday girl look clearly birthday girl. How do we get over to this one? Oh, I just
This is
This is our comeuppance from making fun of the league player
What
Okay, that was a bit too high
I have to be back all the way over here
In me right now
We'll play the beginner map don't worry
We'll do the beginner
Oh
All right
Here's a bunch of nothing
You also
Chongo, what are you doing brother?
They love attention
Mods that'd be great. I think it's everyone's mods are not used to this time. They're like asleep right now. They're like
Yeah, thank you for remembering
Azura
Thank you for the member. Wait, what was the name again so we can all celebrate his name? What was his name again?
Is here for the member. Yeah, yeah, just I'm now recovering from this
Financial ruin because of golf it
Thank you, thank you, thank you. Oh my god
Oh
Freed, I don't know. I'm just guessing
Thank you, Mr. Sigma
Actually, I was wondering would you guys ever go assault con with me?
Yes
Hey, at least they don't know about matter daddies, that's all I'm saying
That's another one. What is matter daddy? Oh, nothing. How about you baby girl? No, that's what's the matter, baby?
Would you rather eat a baby go or a matter, baby?
I don't know what's the matter with you
Oh
Thank you groomed by beaver for the 10 gifted membership scissor, thank you groomed by
You can't ask why a guy has blue balls, yeah
No, X is not the hole X is not the hole
That's not it. Is there a fake?
Frick are they fake holes? They might be yeah, wait, why am I coming flying? Oh, I'm leaving
Wait, can I clip through and see where this leads to why did I keep going?
I'm
Surprise are you kidding me? How did it all fall in? I don't get that. How am I supposed to get there?
Don't tell him. Don't tell him. Don't tell her. Don't tell her
Okay
Hold on wait. No, it's definitely the one behind you. I'm information gathering. I'm information gathering behind you
No, um, it's the one it's the one you're right next to right now, so it's not
Sure, you're getting
You're getting suspended
You're getting suspended if this isn't the oh, no, you're not getting suspended
I thought you were gonna tell me fibbers. I was like first suspension of beaver right now
Oh
In new game
Oh, if I got that in hole in one, I would have okay that was
As there is microphone control is like so good
I think I'm gonna play
Can I stop bouncing for the love of God?
No, there you go. Copy. Um, copy. Oh
Copy
I need to like aim higher
Okay, that was far too hard
Too much power where am I
Okay, this one's hard. I know the power. I have the power
I was a bit too gentle. Oh, let's go
I literally just got in. How did I knock it?
Are you not in
Ah too gentle
Did you just see me? I just made it in I literally made it in and they kicked me back
Same
That's okay. Are you shitting me right now? I'm too hard. Okay
Oh, just get me in
This Johnny just get in I finally got in
Finally. Oh my god. Acey's still fighting with a hill
I horsefuck this game
I serve one got the grease flag. Let's go grease
My god, I got witches up. Wait. Oh my god. What I didn't get anything
I got $500
From who
Garfunkel
Thank you garfunkel for support in the
Main DJ
Mr. J
You're so real for that though
Surely right I see you need to pick a game
What?
Yeah
Wait, what?
Add added instead
Everyone's cold
What's fucking code for ac you're good ac 10%
Oh
Wait, did somebody do what I did what did you do? Oh nothing never mind. No. No. No. Yeah, let's not
Our contract is avoid if we uh
We never did it. I never did anything
Uh, this reminds me of what what what took place though. See our our our lovely
Super bunny man date
I've been chilling gamers up so hard. Gotta let them know
Guess what I'm drinking
I'm forever drinking lean. I'm sorry that sounds bad. I really like lean lean is good lean man
I wish I had the caffeine one of lean
Wait, didn't they know get in trouble? We have to change the packaging. We need to get high
No, no, no this flavor
Now it doesn't what does but he's wearing a mustache and glasses
You're you know in our game is there just click ready. Yeah, click radio
We're in the ace hole. We're in the dj
Wow, and I'm doing fucking terrible
Is it more slippery because it's icy I think right one at a time one at a time one at a time
I need to wait for a zero to get in
Okay, let's go
That's why
That's why you want to
Flip on the ace hole. Oh, yeah, slip on these slides
I got an achievement hit the ball a hundred team
AC has home advantage what the heck
Wait, what did you get 500 zoom like why don't they control the camera?
For who get from who
It's okay
All right, your azure your makes cut and everything because you're so happy
And go back to the hole that we went to before does that count?
What the fuck thank you so much guys
We love you. Thank you for supporting
Thank you
You better hire that moving truck like today, that's all I'm saying you better hire that shit
Azura will go over the names after the collab I promise she'll she'll she'll do it. She'll do it. I'll make her do it
That's very sweet
Everyone is
Baby
Oh my gosh, you are doing fantastic, sweetie, you deserve this
Yeah, 100%
Is your love I'm just gonna start getting you out of that house. I'm spamming in Azura's chat right now
I'm just gonna fucking sit don't don't meet me mods. Don't meet me in Azura's chat. I'm spamming in it
Oh
Okay, we have advantage now that Azura fucked up that last one because she's so happy. Okay, we have advantage
Hold on gamers. Hold on gamers
We've got the good ending. We've got the good day. That's right boy
Keep keep supporting Azura so we can win because she wins everything. She wins everything we play
Real let's go. Oh, no, no, no, no
I'm trying so hard
Geography
Have we got golf claps going?
I can't see
Oh, no, but she's tearing up. She can't see the map
Our advantage
We can win
For once in my life
Why am I on top of scrawny?
Yeah, you like that. Yeah, you like that. Why am I on top of Azura?
What's happening? I'm floating in midair. Is your ping high? No, your ping can't be high
Your ping should be high. My ping is like I my internet is dying right now. Where's the where's the hole?
Watch and
Watch an ac's bowl go fly in and then hearing
I just really
Did it why does he have five strokes?
I don't understand that. I never
What the hell
How's it going? Hey
Kitcha. Oh damn
Mersey's gonna turn yandere. I'm not even kidding. Mersey's turning yandere on us
Please
That laugh is scaring me that laugh is scaring me
No
A.C.'s exhale is so hard
I thought it was so hard
No, stop
Not you guys you guys are fine
Please this is a fucking prize
I'm gonna kill my mom. I'm gonna kill my dad
I can't do this one
I did it
I literally can't do this one
You can't I mean I believe in you
Oh, she literally actually can't
I believe in my little sister. I don't care what it was
I'll hold over there. No my internet
Oh, thank you whoever hit me. I appreciate that. It was me. It was me. You're welcome. Thank you. I see
I can't see
Wait, what's the prize? There you go a little spank for you. Please don't hit me off. I will cry
Oh
Appreciate that. I should have stayed where I am because people will just hit me
Get out of my way
I don't have a chance to do anything
I am not
Shouldn't you right now? I'm stuck on a rock
I know
Where are you?
Can you not move?
Where?
Oh my god, Nori
Hold R. Hold R. Hold R for reset. Hold R for reset. Where are you?
All right, there you go. Yeah, okay. There we go. Good. Okay. Let's go
saved
Leave it
So it's an impromptu karaoke
T-minus. Oh, that was almost a move. That was a good one
Nice, sorry, I got stuck on it. Come on. You have 30 seconds left. I'm very on
We're enabling
ASMR happening right now
Oh, no way, okay, didn't that
Oh, no
Anytime I'm happy to oblige. Nice job
Well, I thought you were a masochist you're getting whacked about Emmy. We thought you were a masochist
Sorry, Emmy. I'm not like this. You just wanded in front of me out of nowhere
Nice job, I see
There's a whole lot. Okay, she's behind us
Okay, that was a bit too aggressive. That's fine. Okay a little bit less aggressive. All right lower that testosterone
Game or move
I need to why can't I hop? I wish this was a game mechanic. Fuck this
Minimum minimum power maximum power
So true breasty
Oh
My mouse is freaking out as well. Oh, perfect
I need to get a new mouse my mouse double clicks like I'm getting extra strokes
Okay, whoa, I didn't just spawn didn't go spank. I can't I see as strongy was
Your sister's wedding. I can't easy
My sister's wedding
He's getting married to him. What's the name? I'm a good deal. I was getting married
Oh
Iron ripar. Let's go. I've been ripar. Let's go
Oh my god, fuck. We're got this. You can jump in golf with friends. So I'm disappointed. This isn't that
Is it in this game? Okay
Blame me because I'm I'm familiar with this game. I'm actually not familiar with golf with friends. Should we it's the episode for me
I'm familiar with golf with friends, but this is my first time playing golf. Yeah, same. Oh
Oh, like I like picking the underdog games. I said
Yay, no
I legit thought I had that there make me hold on. Let's go. Let's go
Suck my motherfucking strap
And thank you. I hate this
Oh my god
Mercy scream yell it to her screamer presentation. I like when she screams
Same it's so fun. Normally she makes the other screams. So it's quite sad
I know it's nice to be on the the receiving end of her screams
Oh
No, this looks like a nightmare
I'm on x games. Oh, that didn't work. I'm on x games
Oh, that's gonna work. All right. All right. Stay. Stay. All right. Stay with me. Strat. Oh, thank thank fucking god led too hard
Too hard. Let's let's ease it up a bit
All right. Oh thank
I keep going into the same weak corner
See this freaking tree
Yes, you see this actual tree
I'm coming up. I'm coming up. I'm coming up. See this bacon. You better get the party started
Finally, I that's what I thought that's what I thought. That's right ancestors gave me ancestors gave me I summon you
If you're gonna spawn golf and at least make your freaking disdain
It's good for the first time. Oh
My god, what was it we kiss balls? Oh
Oh
What the shibbity wait? No, what the shigma? Oh, you're gonna put that my head you're gonna regret the fuck that didn't work
The music is so calm considering how chaotic we are communicating to one another like just like
And the pianos just like
I'm blowing it. I'm blowing my lead
I hate video game and I hate gaming and I
Didn't bring anyone and anything I'm innocent
Right going backwards. I'll take responsibility if everyone wants to pick I'll take responsibility for picking this one
I thought this was the main one apparently it's golf it with friends, but I've never played golf it with friends
Are we allowed to tell the story is there?
Yeah
So Emmy hosts the lobby and we're all joining and is there is like it's just no letting me in
I don't know what's going on. It's not right and
We're like, okay, that's strange. Okay. Well, you know what? We've got enough team
We'll go buy golf with friends and she's like golf with friends
Yeah, go for friends because we're on golf right now. What you never told me that
The verb is really funny. It was so funny. She was like, I'll need to go buy
It was so cute
I
Will wait patiently hit the birth
I'll take it. I'll take it. I came
Surely this is how
No
Can I do that I can
You know what see my ancestors big William Wallace I call upon me. What the fuck are you doing come haunt me?
I'm actually I just want to win one round of golf it before we have to pop off
I'm already popping off
From here from here Zara
From bass don't know Dino
Bastino question mark bastino bastino bastino. I don't know if that's the name or not
Wait
Someone did 650 is there? Can you see that question?
From who
Bastard
I'm on the edge of worry right now
Oh frost dino got it got it got it got it got it got it
Dino
I don't know how I got Bastardo from frosty. No, I'm gonna be honest
Is there that's not the whole wrong hole wrong hole
You're on a different one
That's the whole
Right last level there go down. Yeah. Yeah go down gently the holes just below you
The holes. Yes. Yes. Yes. Yes. Perfect. Okay a little a little 180
Look at it. Look at it like
Going in and out
There's collision
Momato anonymous we love you. We love you
Okay, I'm gonna let them all collate ahead because I know I'm I'm not getting I'm gonna kiss me but come on
I hate this
The ace is killing me
I love getting beat up by you
We your balls are spanked together
Oh, no, how am I going backwards? Wait, there's backwards on the hill
It's a
You're going the wrong way. I literally went backward. Wait, why is it and I'm getting pushed forwards
Oh my god, I'm gonna I'm gonna far take the first spot from scrawny because literally
I need possessed by robert the bruce right now. I'm a teacher all bit about scottish history
All right, big robert the bruce. I he said english
No, you're not having this land and why is he not possessed me right now because what's going on?
I'm out of scottish
I'll do a scottish history stream and you all have to sit in it
His name is robert the bruce big willy wallace big mary queen of scott's i'll teach
Oh my god, I see weapons for you spanked me. Oh, I love you. I say
I didn't have to take a pot for that
There's a moolong song that goes like ancestors hear my plane
Something don't make a fool of me
I'll bring honor to scotland
Oh
I understand the azure goal on our screen right now says azura sus audio roleplay
We couldn't actually put what the content of that roleplay is on the
throne
Oh my god, did I get oh
Oh, not bad. Not bad. Not bad. I'll take it
Oh
Dang it, let's go golfing. Oh, dang it. Oh, dang it. Come on, dang it
I love ac's like frustration screams
It's just
I'm like mine. They're like, you know, like a pterodactyl
Let's go golfing with the girls. Oh, dang it. Oh, fuck me, bro. Okay with pleasure
Actually
Amy
I've got a bone to pick with emmy. Hold on a minute
Your tweet gave me a heart attack because it didn't display fully
It didn't display fully. So the first sentence is I'm leaving viola and I'm like, uh
Oh
I was like at least let me hit the three month anniversary before someone goes
Please
But she was having a little funny hat. I don't know when oh, no, I've not won yet. It's not over until it's over. You know what I'm saying
Oh, what the hell? All right, this is a weird one. No, what?
How did I do worse on the second pot than the first one
Are you in are you in she got a hole in one
How what did you do go ask that I'm watching her stream right now. I'm opening up her stream. I want to see
Okay, okay, okay
No
She beat me by one point because of that hole in one. Are you true, bro?
The americans
The americans are winning. I'm also scottish. It's also for scotland. Ah, you better be scottish. That's what I thought
I didn't drink water everyone drink water hydration check hydration check
Water but I have gamer subs. Is that okay?
Use code mersey for 10 off. Let them know use code mersey for 10 off gamer subs. Let them know
Use code Azura use code she be use code. I see use anyone's code doesn't matter
I'd rather you use the girls codes than my codes. So use one of their codes instead
Let's go
I didn't get a prize. So rude
No constellation but exactly
No, I got third place and I didn't even get a medal or a prize or even or even like an achievement
I didn't get anything either
But I came in first with the participation participation award
Yeah, you get a participation award a trophy to ground my enemies with
What the hell
How do I come in first and then not get anything?
Oh, wait, I can be a hole in one
Sean I want to be your hole in one
I'm gonna be your hole in one. Are you
Oh, please and thank you
This is a war reference
Oh
I'll thank you. Oh, I did not help at all. I thought I was gonna help you mercy not gonna lie
I like being
Give me a moment. I need to rethink that one. Hold on to it. Oh, honestly, I'm like that
I'm like, I need to recalibrate the joke. Give me a second. Hold on a minute
I'm like, there's a joke here somewhere. Just give me a second to get through it. That's all I need
I just need a moment. I'm like
A zero with the hole in one
No way we're getting through this. Oh, it's all about time and all then
Oh, come on, okay, sorry
I'm on a lily pad. Thank you
All right, not too hard but hard enough to make you through. Oh, yeah, not too hard but hard enough to make you come
Give me that par
Oh, no, it'll be a boogie
Well, emmy's now in my way, so
In my way
Can I get uh, can I get a sanity check on our polar bear? I would like a sanity check on our polar bear
Thank you so much for $100 to be again grown. Thank you. Thank you
Thank you
What was the name? What was the name?
groom
Uh, are we all allowed to say that are we gonna? Oh
No
Like like like, you know
Yeah, you want an ASMR roleplay? Sure
Plenty of grooming to go around
I got five birdies
I'm in the water
AC is your make on or am I getting nervous that you're deadly silent because you're about to like go feral
I see let's go
Silence from mercy is scary. Monka is I'm getting
F***ing from aces worse because she's feral polar bear. She's learning how to begin back in civilization again
Oh, no, I'm making it. Oh, I'm getting nervous. I'm getting shaky
I see
Can you hear me?
I was talking. I was talking. I don't know why you couldn't hear me on discord. What the f**k
I was talking. What the f**k? I was worried you were like furious. What did you say?
Got that whole in one year
I was literally still like raging
It was oddly quiet without your raging. Oh very
It's just it's time to rage some more
Exactly
Where am I?
Can I?
This is gonna be a a headache in a hassle unless
Unless right, what's another?
Bro, what the f**k?
Okay, lock in post a picture on twitter with keyboard broken real
What the f**k?
So rude
Hey, I see you went the wrong way. Why'd you go that way? Oh, it's the wrong way
F**k i'm f**king stupid
No
No, no, no
It's like me. I hate video games and I hate
Golf and I hate
You're becoming a hater
Maybe I always was
I was not too good, bro. It's not too good
I see land
Yeah
No, she's gonna stroke out
Try aiming for the wall
Oh
I almost got a hole in one wait, it looks like strunny went in the hole and
I did a rimshot, you know what I'm saying
Sorry, that was disgusting. That was
You were saying you were saying
The ace of fate
It wasn't necessary the end at the end of that was rather
Here I am
No
Oh almost all right, here we go almost f**k
Oh
Hold on
Oh, she's dying. We need to resurrect. I see
someone gift an emergency five
members to
Thank god, oh, thank f**king god
I almost got a hole in one on that one god damn it. I hate video game and I hate golf and I hate
Pro golfer tiger woods y'all tiger tiger woods y'all
Yeah channel tiger woods
Does anyone know any names of any other golfers others in tiger woods? I don't watch
O.J. Simpson the one like wait, no
Wait, was he a golfer?
I don't know. You just say O.J. Simpson. Yeah, I don't think he's a golfer
No, he's a football player that murdered his wife
There you go. Whoopsies
Whoopsies my apologies
Sorry, I don't know
I'm dead
I don't know American things. Okay. I tried my best. I wanted to name one other
You tried that's okay. That's what matters. You tried. Uh, I know fictional golfers like, uh
Paniya, golf, hangya
Don't go flying off the end of the map. There's no end on there's fictional golfers
Oh careful, you know like in the anime and video games
All right, that makes sense. That makes sense. Oh, I was like
No, I'm getting edged by a hill
Oh, baby
Not a triple. Oh, baby a five. Baby a double. Oh, baby
Fuck shebe's gonna win. Thank you so much for the five times. I'm locked in bro. I'm so locked in
Thank you
Five hundred. Thank you. Thank you. Oh, what the fuck? Thank you. Thank you
Hey
Oh, you put me back to the start you little shit. You put me back to the start
You put me back to the start you want to do edgy stuff you do that on your table if you don't do that one here
Don't do it again
Fuck, I'm so close. I literally saw happen in slow motion
Uh
I'll literally rolled on our pov. Wa bam
to my tang
Oh
Great, I can't believe it. Did Azar just trickshot that?
Show me off. I'd believe it
All right, we're gonna play it. Damn. I was too soft
We'll get hard. No, you gotta be
Viagra time
Are you sprinkling salt on your balls when they taste good?
Hey guys, did you know that if you dip your balls in soy sauce, you can taste it?
You should totally do that right now
No, I had I had my viewers do it. They said it wasn't true. No, we're supposed to can you're supposed to tea
You're very that
Sorry, they've already done it for me. I already got many videos of them dipping their balls in
You got video evidence
Yeah, it was pretty nice. It's somebody dipped it in syrup too. It's pretty cool
Like that's nicky. That's when you know, he's canadian pops that stuff in maple syrup. What the heck?
I don't know what the canadian
Like theme song is. Oh, no, that's not what they're called. Sorry. Sorry
I didn't I don't
Oh, that's so cute
Oh, that's so cute. Do you guys have video of the person dipping their toes in the peanut butter?
Yeah, someone's licking it off. I forgot the word for national
I mean if I if one of you guys dipped your toes in peanut butter
Oh
Don't mind me. Don't mind. Oh, forget this thing. I love peanut butter
I didn't realize there was a way. Whoa. I like smooth peanut butter personally
Oh, I'm a crunchy peanut butter and banana on toast. Yum. Yum. Yum. Yum. I don't like peanut butter
Wow drop
I can only I can only eat real peanuts if it's if it's like made out of like
Peanut butter, that's like a hundred percent just peanuts. Yeah fucking shit. Yeah, that's only come on. Let's get only one like me
Strawny's on my arse. I'm cool man. I'm cool man come in you need to keep as long as she be keeps edging
It's all good. She keeps edging
Oh, sorry, I couldn't hear
I
I didn't hear it. I'm refreshing her chat her chat chat
Bleeding hard as you bear snitch
They're all talking about peanut butter. They said oh someone said all of a sudden i'm a dog. Okay, that's funny
Oh
Yes, AC you did it. I see me
That's perfect. I thought i'm gonna be stuck here all fucking day. Yes
Go in we're getting edged. Oh damn. She's doing that ram job
Oh, we love parts
I'm able to sew if Strawny is straddling me right now
We're on the same number. Okay. We must how do we distract she be?
How
Here i'm gonna need some help right now. How do how does she get distracted by?
Uh
Slime she likes talking slime girl slime girl slime girl
Yeah, yes. Oh, I hate slime girls. Oh my god. The invert manifest was in anger
I don't want to see a slime girl. I hate slime girls
I'm so angry. I'm so angry about slime girls. Grrr
Arr
Fuck slime girls. I will fuck them. Oh, I want to
Hear them hear them. You're gonna have to help me out. Come on
Come on
Let the Scottish win that's all my let me win
Yay, that's right. I'm a threat. I don't want you to win. What is happening? Oh
We're getting corralled like animals
Don't you see the game has us pitched against each other but through the power of friendship and love we'll make it
That's right
In the words of icy so true breasty
Oh, no
She choked she choked she choked she choked got chickens
Oh my god
I'm gonna fart. I'm gonna fart an anger
Oh, come on. Come on. Come on. Okay. It can't be too hard. It can't be too hard. Go first. Thank you
Oh, wait, wait, that's pit. You knocked me off the map twice to restart me. That's at least a bit of payback
What the?
Come on. That's right. Keep choking she be keep choking
Oh, no. Oh dear she be am I getting under your skin hen? Oh dear. Oh dear
Member that time the Americans put the tea in the harbor. Aye, that's right. I remember even though I'm Scottish. I remember
I was there
I was there. Mm. That's right. I was there
I was watching it as the Americans revolted against the taxes against us. Aye, that's right
All right. He was there
Okay, that is working right someone else. Give me American history. Come on. Quick
I don't think anyone would understand me if I started licking it on
I don't think anybody wants to hear my new england accent. Go for it. Go for it. Go for it. Go for it
Oh
Oh, that's so cute
This is my accent
I'm trying
I won't lie to you. I don't feel like you
My accent
No, your homework. Why you no doctor?
I mean she can do it. She's like to do it. Hold on. She's allowed to do it before anyone starts getting weird. She can do it
She's a liar. She's allowed
Kissing mercy
I'm allowed to do it again
Hello, welcome in
Hello
There was an ASMR idea too, please
Well, not really ASMR because it was like really aggressive and it would be a lot of yelling
You didn't mean ASMR. I can't have it. Yeah, we're going to the donk anybody want anything from donk's kid. Yeah
Yeah, you're fucking stupid
What
That was not my barp before anyone starts accusing that was not me for once
That was my burp. It was beautiful. That was emi's burp. That was a really good burp
That was a very good burp. Oh fuck. This is hard
I'm uh, I'm gonna let you all thank you for lining me up though. I see hold on. Let me go
Who just spanked me we who just spanked me on up to
We have to go back again
On up to 2d 2d suspension and we're gonna make up a story about how you don't feel well 2d suspension right now
She be
Oh, no way you did that so gracefully
No way you just get knocked in
What?
You just went in for me and then you jumped out
It's the ping it's the ping
Cursed the internet
I'm winning. Oh, I'm still winning. There's a so you're seeing there's a chance
So you're seeing there's a chance
Golf it the game is is paying personified
How am I okay, how are we supposed to get there? Um
Uh, I heard I'm so sorry whoever went in the water, but I heard the s effect so clearly. It was like
Like it was so high quality
Johnny you better go
I have I have but I keep moving someone hit me and I keep moving. I'm not
Still
I'm even
Albatross
Oh
That's a great song
Real gamer blames the pings exactly my ping is astronomical. Look at that ping. This is gonna be so fucking hard
I hate this
Bro if I hit someone in there, I'm gonna be so pissed
The water physics in this game. I have to compliment it when when he used to go in the water
Someone named cps just tipped me and talking about how I killed my tomagotchi
He hasn't forgiven you for your crimes against your tomagotchi
I I've killed many a tomagotchi
Wait, can you kill them? I'm perfectly struck out for this
Oh, shit
Holy shit, holy shit from who let's fucking go
Garfunkel
Thank you, mr. G more like more like bank funkel
Oh
Bang more like I don't fucking know
First places we meet up with you
Jesus trying to get in on fuck. Oh, yeah. Oh, I got in long ago. Check out the scoreboard press shift and see how many it took me to do
Yeah
Shit in me right now. Okay. I've made my ancestors proud. I can mess up everything after this
I unlocked a literal jobby I unlocked a literal jobby
Mercy
Mercy jumped out by accident
Mercy, why do you keep clicking quit?
Because I'm stupid. She's so excited to be next
I was also too excited. Uh, maybe I don't know. No, I miss so many. I miss so many
Close your eyes
It was like spamming like close your eyes. Go to bed something something in your head
dream dream dream dream dream dream
There we go, you feeling it
I'm really feeling it
Are you feeling it now? Mr. Mercy? Should I do?
Uh
What should I do? Should I do hard mode?
Yes, see if there's one
See if there's a map that looks like a zero and then we'll end on this one because we've almost uh
If I think one more game is going to take us like 30 minutes and then Azura can get on with her business
Because she's got a lot of things fun today
I already chose a map by us. Okay. No, no, that's good
It's bad
Thank you. Grimmed by veal or I get strengths again with the 10 gifts
I can't believe you named yourself
You're gonna kill Icy with hard mode
I'm sorry. I see for what I'm about to do
Mercy, oh my god, you're red. Oh boy, here we go. I'm sorry
Click ready, Mercy. My model will be lagging
Oh, I can't wait. Oh, sorry. I forgot to hit ready
I was waiting for you
Oh, we're we're on the farm
Big ass fucking carrot. We're on the farm reef lens
Sorry, D
Ava milk and farm, please. Excuse me
It's supposed to be a jay temple. Oh, this is a weird jay temple
There's turnips on the floor. What's with the random bar at the bottom? That was in here. What the fuck?
No, my radishes
How do you get on the thingy?
Strony. Strony. Don't do it. Strony. I'm not gonna do it. That's a kiss
We are I think we're touch it. Oh, no, we're not touching. Sorry for my puberty. We're very close to touching tips
Damn
Oh my gosh, I could have been honest. This is anyone's win because of how awkward this map is. This is literally anyone's win
Is that a game?
Why do I keep on getting back
One of y'all
We're in we're in. Yes. Yes. Yes. Yes. Oh shit. Yes
Yes
You know what? Since this is the last game. I choose violence
So if it does
Oh, hi, Amy. We kissed
Hi, uh, hi, we're seep
She almost said emmy. She almost said hi, emmy
Hi to herself
Hi, emmy. I still win
They see me rolling
They hate me
Why am I in such a bad spot?
Okay, this should be a little better. Amy. Amy, move first. Okay, where are you?
I'm losing brain. That's slow
Fuck
I'm still at the fucking beginning. Welcome in the lender. Hi, Oren. Yakuji. Thank you. Welcome in
We're back in the fucking building per she be
I'm going. I'm going. I'm going for you. There's like a pat. You've got four seconds to pop three seconds. It's fine
I'm still moving. Can I it doesn't matter?
Wait, what?
We're supposed to go to that island all the way over there. I'm
All the water you can skim across it like a
Oh, but you're not supposed to go inside the water. Oops
Okay, you can't land in the water. Fuck. Why is it doing this?
You have an enemy. It's me. I've chosen violence. I will be destroying all of you
Everyone stay away from she be literally zombie. Where who?
No, why am I in water but not? That was weird
I'm safe. I'm safe in the hole. I see just kidding. I see decided to fuck me up
Um keep going forward over the bridge
No, there's two rogue actors in this game. There's two rogue actors in this game
Be safe be safe my daughter's
Where am I? Oh, shit. I can't even
Wait, I have an idea
Please
I got it. Oh, wait. I'm actually really close. I'm really close. Hold on. Hold on
I keep on hitting that like a one. Come on. Come on. Come on. Come on. Come on.
Game
No, no, no. Okay. Okay. You're fine. You're good. Come on.
Oh, are you serious?
Thank you so much for the 50 dollars. Oh, thank you. Thank you. Thank you.
I'm coming for you. Yeah
I'm coming. I bounced out. Fuck me
Come on
Easy hole in one. Watch this. Watch this easy hole in one easy easy easy
See that
I'll throw at the end so whoever second place can win. How about that? Cause I've already won one. No, no, no. No, I'm gonna
I'm gonna kick you out. That's what I'm gonna do. I'm gonna fart in your eyelashes. Don't don't give me pink eye
I don't need that. Denny's uh, sure you have the cleanest arsehole in all the land
There's no pink pink eye coming from me. I don't know. You got half second farts, Ronnie. So you'll probably
Damn girl, you going you fart with that ass? Yeah, I guess
She is sabotaging me. She was the drunk. Right. That's a two day suspension, right? I'm making up the
I'm making up the lie right now. Um, uh, she be unfortunately, um
Oh, she be she be had a family matter to tend to oh, unfortunately
She's offline for 40 hours. Don't worry. I'm putting up the white page in black text as I speak
I literally uh, hold on. Let me just uh, type it up right now. I'm so sorry for what I must do
Oh, you're lucky we escaped. We are so sorry to report that our precious talent
She be gone bum
I can't do this. I'm losing my mind. Sorry for choosing high and bad
Oh, hey, mercy. What's up?
Hey, um, I love you
I love you. Hey, um, I love you
Oh, yeah, no, you're not you're not through in the game. You're just kissing with your balls
That's what I'm doing
You're just touching balls literally you're not throwing the balls like your womb walls. I don't know. I'll touch your
Call me an iud because I'm about to insert myself. Thank you
Because I'm about to insert myself
The real answer
Oh, no, my love tabs
My I need love. Oh, this looks fun. Actually I kind of I kind of scouted ahead. Whoa
Oh, I almost took the advantage there who whoever wabami to me wabam
What I just hit an invisible wall or did the invisible wall hit you?
Okay, we're in war. Oh
Oh my god, those are like those soba noodles in japan where you the noodles come down to shoot a water
Oh, no, I fell out
Man, I fell out. That's why I said it looked fun
Are you shitting me?
Is that was that scottish?
Oh, I adore when you guys do a scottish accent. I just love it. I'm like, oh my god, please
Oh
What do you mean stroney you went you went after me right you go for me
I actually did it that time. I didn't go after you. Right. Well
Can work can work can actually work that's it. I've had enough
No
The easiest right, I'll give you a sentence and you'll have to mimic it. Okay
So to say you're going to come to my house, you would say my bit. So what the sentence is
I can't I can't wait for you to come to my bit
Is that too long?
I can't wait for you to come to my bit. Yeah
My bit means my house
Literally m a and then b i t is my house
How much money to have you motivate me to finish cleaning her house, so what?
Free for you sweet girl. Hey, see how about you teach us the sentence and yours
Why not teaches
Everyone teaches
Oh, no
I can't believe you've done this
From who from who
Axel rod, thank you for you're getting a golf club axel rod. I think that's what it was
We're clapping you get pregnant get pregnant. We're actually just group clapping you into impreg sorry
No, no, I need to go to a little to the right. Literally. It's too dangerous
Oops today is it where the fuck is the hole?
I can't go straight. I can only go gay. That was like a ping difference
Oh
Oh, just the name where I did it. Oh, here's another freeze for you if it
I'm about to set the fucking trees on fire
I used to look at this he is jibby's edging. I'm edging. Why do I keep edging? I'm not supposed to be the one who edges
Is
Why are you guys saying penalized penalize penalize
God damn garfunco god, yeah
Sleepy Phoenix thank you. Oh shit. I'm falling into the ether. Oh my god. This bridge is like Matt
Oh, it keeps me going. Oh the bridge has it's like a conveyor belt
No, I fell
It's a conveyor belt. Yeah, like it takes you all the way across make sure you aim for the middle
I kid you not aim for the middle or it's gonna keep your trajectory
And Tara Sante shit. Oh, I see I see
Bro, I'm completely through it
I
Gonna share that peepee with the rest of us
Do you have enough to share with the class cuz we're hungry
We're insatiable
I
Never learned to pronounce their names
I don't know how I actually managed to just finish this one
I'm gonna start calling you everybody different names now
Yeah, that's me there you go
Perfect flawless imagine she gets in oh god damn it
I don't know, you know
My god, we're getting carried by the river. This is so cute
I'm so sorry if I hit someone I was me. I hit the birthday girl look a little bit by the
mindful of the current
Oh
wait, can I like
Ever's I'm not hitting it hard enough. I'm too scared. I'm on. I'm on the right lazy live
lazy
Liver
Okay, we made it we made it we made it lazy live or fuck
More like
I know she's
She'd be in my head
No!
In my head, in my head
There ain't no way, how did I do that?
I'm gonna cry
Fuck
You almost hit me
Why does the current take you around the hole?
Around the outside
Guess who's back, who's dying?
Me
Mercy's dying
Tele-friend
For those of you who speak another language
I'm gonna kill myself in Minecraft
Shit
Now hold on a minute, that's why you got hired
Alright, now before anyone's like what on earth is the context of that
It made me or may not have been chosen
For her say amount of words that she used against someone
That was rather inappropriate for most agencies
But you know, we do a little bit different here
What the fuck is up Kyle?
What?
No step though
Fuck up Kyle
Oh shit
Oh no
Where am I?
I'm just coming for blood
I'm about to murder
Wait, how are we supposed to get past the lantern?
You gotta jump it
Oh there's a
Oh he on x-game mode
I made it
This is far away
I didn't mean to hit
Can I please?
You're making
Oh my god I'm a dish
I'mma be, I'mma be, I'mma be
Oh shit, no please
This is not what I wanted
Marcy died in the back room
Is that Zuz make fixing her?
I think it is
Her mic fixing her
Take that filler off right now, I'm gonna fart on it
I wanna hear them scream
She always starts with fart
I'm sorry, I don't know why
Oh my god, you think you use this shit?
You're not even the fart
I'll be going hard
I'll be shitting in the bodega
I don't know, I don't know her lyrics
But apparently all of them are pee, pee, poo, poo, and cuckoo
Like keep it a stack
Like brat, keep it a stack
Oh my, no
Someone taped in Azur's
Someone taped in Azur's fucking chat
Azur ran out of strokes
Marcy ran out of time
I'm not the last place, let's go
It's a joke
Big trouble you today
Oh sorry
Is that
It's me just losing it
I was losing it, I was
Oh it is you
Can you tell who's losing it?
Marcy said it's a joke
Oh
Excuse me
You're excused
Have I gone the wrong way?
No, I think you're in the right spot
We're supposed to hit that really hard I think
Are we supposed to hit the
Target?
I'll tell you
Holy shit
No way
No
Guys, where am I and how am I supposed to get there?
I just fell off the face of the earth
This hard?
I'm still falling
Where's the
Where's the hole?
The blue
The grill
It's the grill
It's the grill like the golden
Paul of blue sapphire
Like in between
Do you see the
Oh my gosh
I think it's almost like a hundred
Yeah
Oh it's the pond
It's a cauldron thing
That's weird
Oh my god
It's the cauldron
The cauldron
That's, yeah
I'm sure it has an actual name
But I have no idea what to call it
I actually know what the function of this
No, I ran out of time
Where'd you go?
I'm not the last place
For what I thought
For AC
You need to pick a game
That you're good at so you can like
Roll us
It's so over
I don't know if we told you
When we first met
We played
That party game
What is it called?
Jackbox
And poor icicle was last again
And I felt so bad
Please no
No PTSD from being last place
And it wasn't fair
Because the questions were like
English questions and they're really awkward
Words that's not everyday vocabulary
So it was like
What is the plural of this word
What is a baby of this animal called
And it was like
This is the one fair on AC
English isn't her first language
It's okay
I just have low IQ it's fine
No
It makes you adorable
Correct
You're not dumb sorry
You're not dumb
I think it was
Thank you
Thank you Mr. Rekuma
Any Rekumas
Any Rekumas in here
Rekumas
Thank you Mr. Rekuma
Oh my god you really are
Fucking higher in the delivery chug
Oh my god the next goal is the
P allure allegation
Oh fuck
Wait what's the P allure allegation
So all
So four of you may or may not
Have peed on microphone
Azura hasn't and I'm next
After her
I said if Azura finishes it
I will finish it
Wait what
Wait I have to look at her because we've all
Peed
Lemonade into the toilet
We made Wink Wink Lemonade
Yes
I just had an idol meeting
I don't know what to do I don't handle idol
Four girls
I didn't look at Azura's channel
Literally
Why is that spanking me
I've had worse things on my own channel
Oh just like
Why is it like there's shit everywhere
It was like
AC need
ME need, SHIBI need and MERSI need
So Azura need is next
And then STRONI need
Just sounds like a grenade to me honestly
STRONI need
I'm just slew
Don't mind me
Gotta hit the middle of the center
You gotta
I literally
Cannot get on this
Oh I did it
I'm not
Once too hard
I can't seem to feign
Let's go
Is everyone struggling to get on this
Platform as well
Bro
It's just you
It's too hard
You can what Tabernac there
I said it Tabernac
I said it
Oh MERSI
Are we going to temple
French Cubic
Is like Tabernac
Wait where's the hole
Why did it put me back
Oh no I finished
I finished
Cubic that's right
That's the hole is that
I'm punishing IME and MERSI
Whenever IME and MERSI misbehave
I punish them with French
But not just any kind of French
Scottish accent French
Kelly, Ladat or Jean-Tui
Elphie, Blue
Come see comme a
Oui
What other French that I know
Oh
Mon pre
Oh je voudrais
une
Peeler allegations
It's awful
Je voudrais une
Peeler allegations
I would like a pee
This is a real punishment
Suspension isn't punishment around these parts
You'll again
Not my internet
Oh no she's typing out
I heard her voice telling
Help
I'm helping you MERSI
I didn't worry
Oh no we tried
I'm trying
Let's get
You
You sound like a character
from in any Sims game
Do a Scottish accent
on a different language
Hello Loita
What are we saying
Is this
Simlish
What are we doing
If you get stuck
Are
Were you stuck the entire time
Or what
Oh my god
Doors stuck
Please
Okay
Oh person
Please for the love of god
Oh no
I think it's supposed to be 25$
Another 10
I'm supposed to go
I want to go this way
AC is going feral
You can't go that way
You cannot go that way
Full on instinct
I need to be sent to the asylum after this fucking
Oh she's gone
Oh fuck
Oh my god
AC had a short that came out
It was her missing a word
And it got so many views
It was so cute
But it got so many views and I was like damn AC
Keep messing up your English
Let me form some clips off you okay
Okay let's go
No my internet
Oh no are you still in game
The best I've done
Oh no
What the fuck
Is this asylum
It's not asylum
Asylum
And it's
Carnival Example
Carnival
It was such it did so well
I was like fuck you
That's right keep messing up your English
How far I'm going so hard
Oh right don't do it too hard
Don't do it too hard up that
Too late
Oh and I did it too gentle naturally
You know
Whoopsies
You gotta hit it just right
The designs are quite nice
Nobody can take the internet out again
I hear she be
I'm insane
I'm dying
Are you in game
I'm still in game
Just keeps cutting out
The game is the internet is like
I know what's important here
Make sure she can continue playing the game
Literally what the fuck
Okay there are bridges to go down
So you don't need to whack too hard to get to the bottom
I like to whack hard
Oi I just was fine
Oh my god it looks like
It looks like Emmy had picked up Strani's ball
They're taking me away
They said they've had enough of me being in game
It means that I'm kidding
I love you
I love you all even though
I hate the golf
It's okay I will do the same exact reaction
In golf friends
Nice
Nice nice nice nice
Nice nice nice
Let's go I see
Nice nice nice nice
Hold on hold on
Bye
We did it we did it
Okay so what's this one
Yeah you go go high
Bless you
Oh I made it
No I didn't
Fuck my life
Not bad not bad
Please
Oh my god please
Ah
Okay
No this is possible
I'm too strong
Thank you Taff for this
Oh don't mind if I do
Don't mind if I do
Let's get on the cam
Let's see what's happening with my daughters
What are we 5 nights at Freddy's characters
I'm flipping up the
No
I'm getting the action replays
Of all he is
What are you supposed to do
Oh my fuck
Keep going that way is there a
You take like a right angle turn
Are you serious bro
Brother
Isn't this Sudoku
No
I say Sudoku
It's Sudoku
No
That's the meme
I didn't even know
I'm gonna commit
Sudoku
Sudoku is a number game
Yeah I know
It's my favorite game I like the game
I'm really good at it
I'm great at Sudoku though
What whoa hold on a minute
You better not
10 seconds
Just kidding
Doesn't matter
Nice knees
True
This will be my last frame
I'm committing Sudoku
No
Oh well it bring a lot of publicity though
I'm teasing
I know it just for you strongy
No I'm teasing before anyone takes that
Seriously relax
Relax
For the views
No that's terrible
I shouldn't do it for the vine
I ain't gonna do it for the vine
That's rude
You can bang the gong
Where are we supposed to go
Oh that way
We can't hit the gong
Oh no make sure you do it
Oh right no it's fine oh my god
Whoa
You got in
That was amazing I just saw that
Strongy I'm so sorry
You're not sorry my ping
My ping's better than yours
That's pretty accurate
Oh no
Let's see
There's a wee lotus flower
That was a great trick shot
Oh my god it's Sakura
Kawaii ni Sakura
Well
Sorry
My favorite is strongy just being really
Really bad
Japanese
I used to be able to say
Well actually right this is really terrible lord
I can only say sentences from hentai
So I can say stuff like oh that feels good
In Japanese and like
Stop with the brother
Give us an example
We need a taste
It's like taste test
Onii-chan
Oh my god
What the fuck is that
It's me
What do you mean what's that
That's me
It sounds like you at all
It doesn't feel good
It wasn't
Taisho puo ni to
Oh no
Wait listen
I just had like a terrible thing
Pop in my head
Should I say
Dare
I was like
Damn imagine
Off collab taste
Test stream
Where I just taste everyone's vagina
Oh my god
Like
Oh
Taste test stream
With my god
Oh my god
10 out of 10
That'd be a great stream
Oh my god
10 out of 10
Oh man
I'm speechless
I can now because
I can't comment on what you would like to do
Off collab
I'm down for anything but
What the fuck
Right everyone I'll be buying everyone
Yoga and hydrating for no particular reason
Let's get strawberry flavored fannies
Strawberry flavored fannies
So
The off
Mercy suite I want to taste
Yeah
Sweet
Oh my sweet
Smile sweet
Sadistic surprise
Surprise
Are you kidding me
Mercy mom
How did you guys get out of the stairs
The stairs take you up
Yeah
But how I can't
Wait they're not
Oh no she's rolling down the hill
She's rolling all the way down
Bye
Amy's in patrolling
They try to catch me riding
Cushing
They're holding
They're trying to get me riding
Yo I'm not lost
Try to catch me riding
Wait what
Oh shit
That was
This is like Harry Potter's type stuff
Can I like just fall down
Into this one
Where are we supposed to go
Please please please
Down the tomb
Where do we go
Down there
I can't even
Where the fuck
It's on the floor
That's the old hole into it
Is it where it's put
Yeah it's 17 we're on for 8
I can't even find it so I'm looking around
I don't know where to go
I can't see
Is it actually
It's on the ceiling
On the ceiling
Oh you
You don't have to tell me twice
You don't have to tell me twice to you
What the fuck is on the ceiling
Okay
Why can't I just go all the way down here
I can't see anything though
That's such bullshit
The hole is literally down there
No no that's the old one
That's the old one
It's up
I'm fucking stupid never mind
I really thought I found
Out like an amazing way
To get it
I already tried that way
Gravity changes
If you look around
Gravity changes when you go up
So up is down but when you go up
I don't know how to get up there
I'm sorry
I'm on the wall
Mercy do you see where she is
You need to go on that side and then
Eat yourself off the platform
Yes perfect
Eating
What the fuck
Where am I
You're
Oh let's go
Oh we love you
No there's only one second
No I wanted to do it
It looks so good
I wanted to finish
I was so close
No
Oh my god
I got a plunger
I got a Joby again
You got another shit
I got two Joby
We did it
I got the plunger you got the shit
I got a pink hat
So who's got the fart
I love it
I love when they do that
And rap where they just go
Random
Country boy
I love you
Okay
Right I am going to say
A grand spank and thank you for everyone for showing up
For Azir is doing a thon
And we got to have Vila our time together
I'm happy to say that
No there will not be a white text
In black font coming out anytime soon
I'm getting terminated guys
Yeah it's just straight termination
I'm going to have someone skin walk a Shibi
Just warning you now
I'm teasing
I just come back till next stream
With a different voice
And we act like nothing's different
What are you talking about
Oh my god
250 anonymous
Anonymous
Thank you Mr. Anonymous
What is the
Agendination is myself and the other
Girlies are going to all redirect into Azir's
Donathon you will all be forced
To sit and watch it
Azir has put so many
Plans into today's
So please do
Even if you want to lurk in the shadows
You're more than welcome to
Definitely support Azir today
Wait where the fuck am I
On the main menu
Close movie to the studio
Like a dumb
What the actual fuck
You all get redirected into azir
And you're going to kiss there
There are some
Yes there are some girls that are doing streams
But after their streams anyway
They're going straight back into azir
So please don't worry
It's not a problem
Okay
Okay thank you
So so much everyone I'm going to jump out of
Voice chat and wrap up my stream real quick
But thank you so much for playing
I was a hoot in a holler
I had a lot of fun
Thank you bye bye
I'll talk to you later bye
Bye bye
Damn fucking right
The scott takes to home
Ahhhh
I'm flexing you can't see it right now
But I'm flexing so hard
Oh what's that what's that
Robert LaBruce in my bloodline
Oh a bit of big Willy Wallace
Ahhhh that's right
That's right I take it home
I take it home for
It's coming home for Scotland
Oh there is
Scotland
When will we see
Flex them twigs
One that's hilarious
Two fuck you
Thank you
So so much narrow for the
Super chat dusk slayer for the Super chat
Doctor no shame for the 10 gifted
Memberships I appreciate it
I do apologise I couldn't interact too much
You know how it is when we do
Collaboerations
I promise you I am actually looking at you
A lot and reading but I don't say it out loud
Because I don't want to talk over the girls
But I'm going to fart inside Azura's nostrils
So freaking hard
I've told her remove the filter off of discord
And she's like there's no filter on my make
And I can't hear her at the time
She's getting bent over my knee and spanked
Even though she's like
Well technically she's like a billion times taller than me
Because she's a giant Tess
Now for the agendation reeflings
For me personally
I'm going to end this stream and redirect into Azura
But I'm going to boot up a very quick
Drawing stream
Now the stream says I'm doodling
My gen mates
But when you open up the doodling my gen mates
Stream you're going to know it's not
My gen mates it's for Azura
Okay Azura just reached 7.5
Oh my god you guys are support
Bro I was joking about her
Opening up
I was joking about
Her hire in the moving truck
After today
I don't think we're joking anymore
I mean
Shit
Fucking hell you guys are supporting her at the Wazoo
Thank you everyone who has said
I tried so hard to be like
Oh my god Tihi
Thank you XYZ
Obviously I can't see
Who's singing and Azura is obviously
Talking away to herself too
The reeflings understand
The assignment
I'm so happy when she moves out
Holy shit you guys are getting spoiled
Getting heart
Anyone and everyone that watches her content
Is going to get spoiled
But yes
I'm so freaking happy
She's doing so good
If she's already at 7.5k
Holy fuck
She like about to move the fuck out
I don't know what her agendination is
For the rest of the day
I'm not quite sure
But yes I am going to
Redirect into her
That chaotic collab
Per AC
Oh my god I heard AC expel
Like her Psy
AC has a really specific Psy
That tells me she's fed up and she's about to go feral
And she went feral
I was so nervous I was like no AC no
But per acical
I'm sure we'll play a game
That she will
You know roll and smoke us on
I don't know what that game might be
It might be Fallen Monkeys
And if we do that off collab
Not her idea
My idea we'll play Beyblades
And like Buckaroo
And then that monkey thing
That monkey game where you pull out
Pull out like a sword thing
To stop them all falling down
And like Jenga
I just about said Tenga
Well I said it now but you know what I mean
But yes
I'm going to redirect into her
I'm going to get a cup of tea and I'm going to rehydrate
Like it's sweating through that
But yes please do feel free
To lurk in the background of Azura
It does not matter
You do not have to give money please
Don't feel like you oh my god I must give money
No you don't have to
Even just lurking and giving the stream a little like
Is super duper helpful and it really is
Fantastic so
I'm going to redirect into her now
Give me 5 minutes and I'll start up in
What about Twister in Underwear
Oh yeah you want us to film that yeah
What is it
Is that the monkey game where you stab a barrel
With plastic swords
Yeah there was that one
And then there's another one where it's see through
And if you pull out the thing
It like makes them all fall down
But you don't want them to fall down or something
Like that I can't remember
Asi's mind went feral
When she said like oh I shouldn't say it
I thought she was going to say something about funny Teehee
Oh no she went straight for it
She wants a taste testing of everyone
Asi
One that's wailed
Two I'm so fucking down
I thought it would be really funny if we did an off collab
That all the girls like spanked me
One by one for being like your shit
Haha
But that's just me
Me being like oh my god Asi
That's so shocking also
Me secretly like hey are you guys down for this
I think this is going to be really funny
But yes
As I said I'm going to redirect into Ezra
Please hang out and give me 5 minutes to get my stream prepared
Because I need to pop a few things on stream
I'm going to make a cup of tea and I'm going to go for a tinkle
Because I'm not normally up at this time
And I forgot to tinkle before
I started no stream
You mean tumbling monkey's game
I found it and maybe a collab on the other site
I thought you meant you were down for the off collab taco eating
I mean
If the others were down for it
If your friends would jump off a cliff
Would you follow them too
If they're down for it
She
Who am I saying no
So I was like yogurt is for everyone
Fruit for everyone
Hydration for everyone
And then Asi will be like
That one's strawberry
Someone's had some mango yogurt
Okay
Redirect into Ezra
I'm going to get
And then give me 5 minutes
To start up our secret drawing
For Ezra
Because I'm not actually drawing my 10 minutes
I'm drawing Ezra
Okay
And if the redirect doesn't work
Then I have a fantastic link and chat for you
7 bowls with 7 flavours
5 kuchi flavours
Can she decide who's been eating what yogurt
Right enough
Enough of my shenanigans
I see in 5 minutes
If not
Even if you've got it on in the background
Leave it on your computer
I appreciate it
That was a big smooch
We should do it again
Okay 2 big smooches
Because I won
Okay I'll see you in 5 minutes
Bye bye